on today's podcast a man who was
suggested by Robbie Williams
bless his heart the maker of faith taxi
and other non websites you've probably
been on before
yeah Jamie thanks for coming welcome
thank you
I don't usually do interviews as was
simple never never do interview I did a
keynote once but it's mainly for trade
like for people in the auto industry for
the trade publications and things but
what was it about the adult industry
that you gravitate towards and ended up
working in porn thinking that gonna be
on lots of different sets looking at
naked ladies in the flesh and reading
all the stories and thinking just
believe in the hype around the the porn
and like the glamorous side of it yeah
and really finding out is not that
glamorous it's really boring
sir so yeah but right right the very
beginning was just an opportunity right
I would class myself as an entrepreneur
but a pretty spectacular failed
entrepreneur who tell us about the
failure before you got in the industry
yeah there was one of the ones was solar
water products so we were trying to be a
more horror than poor luck yeah we were
trying asked crikey China heat up like
user creating ovens and trying to heat
water so that would get above 63 degrees
or whatever it was so we passed your
eyes for the third-world countries but
using the Sun I know
yeah yeah I mean you won't get any
credit for that no use too important
yeah I'm a little brownie points they've
they've been tipped off that yeah that
failed and we just couldn't get the
temperature up really then there was a
toothpaste really yes an on foam in
toothpaste use in cardamon so the
toothpaste was brilliant yeah but yeah
that didn't really work so what was the
actual appeal of a cardamon Nami
it was very people have like phobias
about foam but this toothpaste was
particularly like really really really
good toothpaste but it yeah just that
didn't take it smart for me to hear that
you were like this and then and then
important was your so Avenue to me yeah
for tuning well it was it when you were
younger we always saw looking for
opportunities it was you always gonna be
that guy yeah me and my brother we used
to do we used to be in the Cubs moms we
used to do like Bob a job so we always
used to do two jobs for ourselves and
one for the for the Cubs said we was we
was always looking to how to how to make
money and I guess sir I come from like a
traveling family no it's a my my mom was
from traveling for Henry sir they're
they're always wheeling and dealing so
you've got it in your blood Shirley
so you always traveling quite a lot no
because she married out the fraternity
Ron so they settled down they had when
was younger that like a hotel bed and
breakfast then they turned it into old
people's home and then they turned into
home for the mentally ill was that why
would you why did that progress with no
money right yeah so instead of like 20
pound bed and breakfast he was on like
150 pounds weak from the government to
look after these these people yeah and
then if you looked after the mentally
ill you got 300 or whatever it was at
the time yeah they were sort of in that
yeah so they've made a lot of money
pretty quickly
they would go through though by other
big like premises this was all down in
home Bay in Kent so they ended up with
three really big homes so about 120 beds
in all they've retired and my brother
Michael wrong now yeah they're aware
that you're in this industry
oh yeah mum mum she passed away back
last nearly a year ago so you can in the
porn industry for a while so that were
they aware of it yeah they were they
weren't very like happy about I didn't
really tell them the beginning because
it's there's just a real stigma of
course couched so it's like it's 2006
are like 11 years where I've been in in
the adult industry that's a long time is
that it is you're sort of what we were
talking about before we went on but
you're the point is she's changed so
much because of the Internet Anu was
seen as someone who might have been
instrumental in the change because you
started you port yes I was part of the
team that that started started you porn
sir before you porn everybody had to pay
for porn a bit of memberships so
literally you had hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of little like
husband-and-wife teams or at film
content they put it online they put the
paywall their right arm and they'd make
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
a month how much money would people pay
per month back then like was it quite we
think then 20 $30 a month which is
actually quite a size yeah and it's
still the same price today now they
still make money in from that yeah a lot
because you do you have tens of
thousands of members we have like over a
hundred thousand tube sites changed the
gamer because I remember the air came
around I was like I don't really have to
pay for a one anymore I can just fly
wait video it's not full video games
when the tubes first come along
we launched you upon 26th of August 2006
tube sites had already like the the porn
troupe sites had already been there
about a year but they haven't really
really taken off because people were
were uploading clips that were like 20
seconds and up to like a minute long
because like teaser well yeah but these
these won't be an uploaded by companies
these have been uploaded by users that
liked the things but not a lot people
knew how to rip a DVD how to record how
to like download a DVD then upload it
bandwidth was very expensive and very
very slow so thinking like if they've
just downloaded a scene like a 20 minute
scene that could have taken them about
three hours to download now they've got
to upload that scene to you poor poor
knob or what whatever no they just used
to use to do it for so that's why I sort
of struggle with you know the guy who's
for sure I don't know why they would
have would have done it but they did in
their hundred mm unity spirit you got
good stuff back um well yeah you you
shared the your favorite somebody else
shares and it just it builds out the
community but at that point there wasn't
any name to the person that was
uploading it the body there were no
communities it was just literally we for
instance we we turned you porn on as a
domain and the framework we turned it on
the guy that turned it on there wasn't
no video or they think the first video
that he put on there was a video of a
gondola in Venice he phoned his dad and
said ah can you go to this website and
make sure it's it's working his dad knew
and he'd started like this framework
with an a heat court at youporn it
thought it was really pretty funny
because of YouTube obviously what's the
URL so yes
why are you oh I've got a story about
remind me later which is pretty pretty
funny so he was on the phone swing to
his dad for about half an hour so the
the website had gone on online he put
one video on of the gondola video by the
time he'd got off the phone he was gonna
upload the first porn video he went on
there somebody else had already found
the domain and uploaded a video Wow that
the within 30 minutes then you build
that they will come within the first
week I think there were there are about
500 videos of people uploaded not great
big hour long videos but little snippets
of porn videos another difference to my
knowledge when I first went on new porn
it was about people being up lower than
that one video was a lot of time that
they had made themselves I guess that
was the idea in my head yeah yeah some
of the that that content is very
dangerous that's a when you're
supporting those well isn't not only
that but you don't have any documents
you don't know if they're over 18 but
because you don't as a as a tube site
because you don't own that content and
when people are uploading the content
they tick a box to say they own the
content they have the rights and they
have all documentation for the content
obviously most people don't but they're
they're clicking yes at cooking upload
but what what we realized was as we
launched end of August 2006 we didn't
really start going viral till November
2006 then by March we we were having I
think it was like half a million
visitors a month to the site which we
thought was like crazy what we do think
was really crazy is we didn't have
enough money to pay the bandwidth bills
I was gonna say that
a lot for a small startups so sin
November we had the bandwidth company
phone us to say hey we need you to wire
us like ten thousand dollars because
your your bill is going to be huge where
you getting all this traffic from and
they're like we don't know because we
don't we didn't advertise but we just
grew through through word-of-mouth
but we've realized right the very
beginning because of the like the
threats we were getting from content
producers and some really heavy like
that dozen people who make porn to your
site which meant that they were getting
the traffic to this yeah meaning that
they they saw it that we were stealing
their content stated because their
memberships would have started going
down you were the love Bible of the pod
Wilbur yeah maybe but I know that we we
just weren't received very well whether
people create in the content they're
spending thousands to create this
content put on their pay site to sell
thousands literally tens of thousands of
memberships a month which they were to
all of a sudden see their their content
on tube sites like like you porn a new
porn being protected with the DMCA law
the Digital Millennium Copyright Act
that was created because otherwise every
single every single like law call in the
world would grind to a halt through
people trying to sue for copyright
infringement so they created the digital
Manila Digital Millennium Copyright Act
the DMCA so that if if you found that I
had your videos on my website you have
to let me know with you have to fill out
the DMCA form specifically if you get it
wrong I don't need to conform to it but
when I receive your notice have 24-hour
safe harbor to remove your video but I
could have had your video on my website
for a year
Selin and it could have had 20 million
views and I'm selling adverts on my
website as soon as you realize that I
have your thing and say oh sorry
take it down and there's nothing you can
do and then another user will upload
that video because it really yeah and
then recently there was a picture that
went viral on Instagram of someone who
had a check from you pornhub I think it
was for the amount of hits that did hard
on their video yeah because the dynamics
have changed now the the we if we go
right right back to the very beginning
because none of us in the in the youporn
team there were seven of us in all it
ever ran an adult company we did we
didn't know anything about adult company
we we've just like technology but we
realized the way sir we were a glorified
ad network that's what we were just our
YouTube those three days oh yeah
so but we've realized right the very
beginning the the business model that
we'd created wasn't sustainable we were
we were kind of we were sitting at the
top and we knew that we were going to
kill everybody below us you know if we
didn't feel to the money that we were
getting or the traffic that we were
getting back to the people whose content
was on our web site like YouTube do
basically yes we we didn't think it was
it was fair that we would have all of
this content that you would need to DMCA
us to get the content removed we
couldn't control what our what I use a
base were uploading because if we looked
at those videos before they went online
it meant that we were secondary
producers of that content which mean
that we had to hell hold all of the
documents for that content with model
releases and comedy a lot so we couldn't
be doing so we had to let everything go
on there we realized the business model
wasn't sustainable we realized that we
really were the true evil the end to
this this arrow in
sorry wall dude yeah everybody hated us
image anyway well we were told right
there's so many emails you know these
death threats I mean how real are we
talking here fairy
we had one about like a silver bullet
with like youporn written on it and if
we ever go to a trade show he's gonna
shooter something like wow this and this
is a northern guy who probably would go
through with it yeah all right yeah
listen
yeah it's so how we didn't go to try to
any horror Robby's does that you go yeah
yeah how did you react to that at the
time here also just lady listen we're
just technology guys who yeah we were
just technology guys knowing exactly
what what we were doing to real
establish huge industry might is from
defend to their models severely which is
something that now people are most
glorified a little bit online ideas just
what the mainstream we where where the
industry was was like lucky is that you
pon did come along because the other
tube sites were in existence they'd
really didn't care no they just wanted
as much porn on there they want to tell
as many banners as possible but we did
actually care and so we we tried to work
out a way of how can we how can we help
the production companies that are
spending all of this money producing
content that their viewers their users
are now not subscribing because they're
looking all their content on our website
what can we do so we we invented
something called the content partner
program where you as a Content producer
you would edit videos how we would tell
you how to edit because we had so much
data to say people serve likes millions
of people watch this video
and it had a high rating because this
video had these these things in it too
had to start middle and an end in and
the comp shop was was in the ending it's
really technical it just really it
really is a science of how and that's
it's how we actually grew you Pont how
big it actually got was because we we
come up with an algorithm that trapped
the the footprint of every user so we
could as a user you would need to come
in and watch I think I think it was like
four videos if we foot printed you and
the four videos are you watched and if
you rated them if he was a guy that
would rate them we we then knew what
your next steps we're gonna be what next
videos really yeah yeah if you watch
like 789 videos without clearing your
cache we could narrow it down to around
about out of the when we were law when
we launched this algorithm we had a
hundred thousand videos we could narrow
it down to the next round about to three
hundred videos we knew that you were
going to click on that one in a
different niche so he could be like
transsexual it could be anything
or these footprints but what that
enabled us to do was we could preempt
what you were going to like so we we had
like a we recommend and that was one of
the the most used things on our website
where people like how do I like that but
it wasn't only valuable for the use of
retention and the user experience but it
was so valuable for pay sites you for
being able to advertise and we could say
we've got this demographic here of 15
million users that we know that they're
likely to want to go in and look at teen
content or look at reality content
as if they make stuff almost Taylor -
yes we would because we had this content
partner program so feel free go back to
2007 we launched content partner program
so that meant that hey I know we've got
a lot of your content on our site
already but we will badge that give you
banners under the video player and we're
going to direct our traffic to your pay
site we reached out to two or three
different production companies big
production companies and they were like
are you crazy
why would someone that is on a free tube
site looking at my content want to then
click on the banner to come through and
pay me $30 for a membership and we're
like but we think that they will and
they're like you just taking crazy
you're not gonna make any friends here
so we were like [__] what do we do
because we've really believed in this
content but for us it was logical it was
going to happen but we we also were
having a lot of visitors at that time I
think we would have been up to I think a
million visitors a day by the time we
launched the idea yeah but for the odds
can you remember roughly what the
company was making a month's at that
point yeah but I can never to can't talk
about nor I know Pam with Bill our pate
was a half a million dollars Wow yeah
just for bandwidth him just for payment
that's been incredible yeah but we
didn't have many other costs yeah I
suppose you know you were sort of and
that revenue was good I mean done and
then yeah there we also got revenue from
cams so that was just really good so we
would have just tapped so like for the
the cams but the alarm goes on though
yeah yeah well did you surprise yourself
then on the
- experience yeah user experience for us
was was everything because we never
wanted to spend any money advertising
youporn we wanted everything to be
word-of-mouth we wanted everybody to to
be proud to go tell their friends that
my god you should go on new porn they
don't have video ads of guys grow in
their their [__] from 8 centimeters to 8
foot yeah so we didn't have video at we
the reason we used to spend so much on
bandwidth is because in the early days
we knew that the worst experience for
their end user is buffering because you
can't buffer your bank it's not a good
thing you make a psycho
yeah you can't you can't bother your way
and that was that was like our unique
selling point was we ya know no
buffering you know there was nothing
yeah nothing nothing worse so I guess
it's unusual because actually you're I'm
guessing about a heterosexual guy
sitting in a room having to work out
what a lot of heterosexual guys sitting
alone in a room want to not over and
essentially your user experiences yeah
we didn't have to work out what they
wanted to wank oh because they chose
that their selves though so maybe they -
you know via the data yeah data is is
key to everything no matter how big or
you're a [__] essentially yeah
but you you can get bogged down in data
that's the sir that's the thing
especially I guess in the porn industry
where it's sort of a subjective thing
away
you can just drill down too much and
then your yourself becomes a very tired
list like you've never been on a shoot
and seen one in real life you're a guy
in an office who's running a successful
business well we didn't even have an
office because we are the timer is based
in the UK and we didn't want to run it
from the UK I had a partner in America
just because of all the we were just
scared of everything right because we we
didn't really we didn't really because
you Palmer started more of his joke you
know we didn't really realize what it
was going to turn into but we very
quickly realized come November after a
couple of months that what we have
explored
yeah it's we we had to we had to do
something so we we would just travel
everywhere we'd be on a like a Skype
video call mend the domain partner and
we just literally spin the globe and go
that's let's go meet them we'd race
there so we used to go to Hong Kong a
lot because you have the cash no because
we just wanted to get out we want to get
away from from the kids get away from
the wives just so that we could just sit
in hotel rooms and just work out what
the hell we were gonna do it must be
quite surreal it was it was it was
surreal it was scary because of the
threats we were getting from an industry
that we knew that we could be really
good friends with but it was scary
because where the hell are we gonna get
all this money from because their
advertisers you would you would sell
them your traffic or you would give them
the ad spots for 30 days and then they
would have like 90 days to pay you for
the hot spots and we're thinking we just
don't have the money to pay our
bandwidth bills so they're going to turn
us off on the bandwidth so we and we
didn't want to meet anybody either
face-to-face we just would not meet
anybody we were just so scared right
someone would just go you're the guy
being on because you do we didn't know
who was connected to you taking these
desperate very seriously and yeah well
for the first year at the site I called
myself Nora that's where my skype name
comes from why not because my nan used
to always say like [__] in an orange I
call myself you yes I was Nora for the
first year and then start to use my
initials by JT well you know when the
money's coming in eventually you know
you do start seeing the profits how did
your lifestyle change what sort of
life's that will you live them before
and then what did it go up do because
I've seen your Instagram and you yeah
you do pretty well for yourself okay I'm
in the lifestyle and I admire what
you've done
but what kind of jump did you make would
you say with with you pond not much
really
because we were just so worried you know
about it could just disappear overnight
so nothing ready Shoney's plus we were
working on 18-hour days so because there
was seven of us that looked after the
whole of the whole of the company so I I
was mainly traveling three weeks of the
month and then you'd go home for like
four or five days then you just jump on
a plane to go do work wherever we wife's
at this point she's sort of like you
know I mean because if you're getting
death threats you know so she doesn't
know no but she knows you're working in
pull knows we work in in porn just use
don't talk to me about it
right so just her kids as well yeah
raising the kids
kids no hope would Joe have been seven
years ago he would have been about 15
right I think he knew so of course all
his friends at school
no sir he went to hero status so I was
known as DuPont yeah yeah honk I say he
used to call himself the youporn kid
Harry Harry was he's 2 years or 3 years
younger than Joe say he used to call
himself Harry Hefner no you have no see
I've got seven kids a lot of markets
what it what did this experience it to
that point what do you feel like you've
learned about like this industry in this
business the people are crazy
mm-hmm is it the Wild West that it comes
across I thought it used to come across
us I think before before youporn started
then yeah for sure I hear so many
stories about the trade shows where
people are they're blown fifty hundred
thousand dollars on parties right and
just thinking the money is absolutely
incredible
mm-hmm and it just really was and until
the to tights come along because so that
really did impact the subscriptions yeah
even though you try to divert the
traffic oh no no everyone was doing that
we had so many others yeah yeah because
it wasn't just us but we were the
fastest growing so from November through
to November 2006 I think we were one of
the fastest growing web sites on the
Internet at the time we were growing
like ten times faster than Facebook it
reminds me a little bit of the music
industry where you had you know album
sales were massive and then all of a
sudden hasser come along - it's just a
flat line into the industry and then
people have
to adopt different yeah the ones the I
think we when we when we started the
content partner program so if we go back
to yeah 2007 so we actually had two
companies that said okay we'll break
rank with everybody else because
everybody else on the forms I like hate
the troops I hate you porn in particular
because we we just broke out and we
started getting big they it was naughty
America that were a real big site and
another one called CD girls I remember
yes the CD goes yeah CD girls like CD
naught or see me know CD like CD naughty
America I was a huge so yeah and they
stopped because they adapted ya know to
America's good did you see their fee our
advert that went absolute why are we not
in the industry so I don't feel like
we're I know this would have been on
Instagram it was everywhere ago I had
the VR goggles on and was caught
masturbated and realized his girlfriend
come in that was go out with a video
that they did themselves but the
girlfriend supposedly uploaded it and
yeah that went pretty viral for them you
know it's pretty funny scenarios yeah
North American CD girls they said okay
let's let's try this content partner
program out so they gave us we asked
them for 30 videos each we put one a day
with the content partner banner
underneath now this content partner
banner so how the content partner
program works so you're a new porn
you're watching a Naughty America video
you like that video you see the banner
underneath you think ah click that so
you could have like an offer like one
dollar trial so you click on that you
then leave you porn you go through to
North America you look at their website
you think how this is this is really
good I've just really enjoyed that video
but I've seen for free ID and but it's
only a a four or five minute video
there's the 24 minute long version of
the video just really enjoyed yeah I'm
gonna gonna join pays $30 youporn we get
$15 of that you know sir we're we're
good to the industry but we want to
actually make our money too so we become
what is known as an affiliate so we we
send that user through to you to North
America he buys a membership we get half
of the membership lifetime membership
fee so he could be a member for a year
and we're getting a lot of money so
Naughty America we were put in a video a
day for the first month they would get
in so many bad comments on the industry
forums because they started dealing with
us the industry don't like it yeah so I
think for Naughty America
we sold our they over 5,000 memberships
in that first month was very and that's
good for them at that time yes two
dollars a membership is very good and if
they're going downhill anyway yeah so we
had an agreement with them that they
wouldn't really talk about the
memberships until the end of the month
at the end of the month feel free to
tell everybody what what you're doing so
they did all of a sudden nearly every
content producer every website that got
the tubes they were like I want a part
of that so they did they all started
hittin us out approving so yeah and then
all of a sudden we've gone from two
content partners within a year with over
2000 companies signed up with us we
ended up being the biggest affiliate in
the porn industry because of the sheer
amount of traffic that we had and we
were growing our traffic was growing
very very very fast when we started the
content partner program that we had like
20 million visitors a month maybe 30
million uniques or is that people
that's that's less people at our peak
our peak was 2000 March 2010 where we
had three hundred and seventy two
million users and uniques were around
about 170 million
yeah about sixty you know about 45% us
then Germany was a big marketing force
even though that we were we were bad
German Germans
I'm just through IP by Caesars got VPNs
essentially right yeah
and so could you see exactly what those
countries liked is yes is now porn does
that every you know 10 yeah yeah that's
always varies good because that creates
a lot of mainstream right nice the the
pornhub guys are amazing
and marked it absolutely the world's the
sponsor of so they were both high
constraint oh this just keeps rolling
and so so this is your peak no 2010 10
March 2010 was yeah 307 - it was a 20
according to Alexa which is the
obviously the website ranking that's all
no well that's the money saw collects
was there any months where you're like
[__] huh
there's a check sum you are you had like
nearly every month yes sir the we write
the very beginning like I said we were
really worried because we didn't have
any money so we we got on to the the ad
networks the dating companies and the
cam companies to say right we're gonna
give you all of this all like the tabs
we're gonna give you a set percentage of
our banners you see our traffic you see
our growth you know the gross not gonna
stop we're gonna prepay we're gonna
pre-sell this content or this space you
for two months but we've really need you
to prepay these companies were worth
hundreds of millions so they're like
yeah we'll do this for you because it is
then we're very loyal to them they're
very law to us good so they start to
prepay in a lot of money then at the end
of the two months if our traffic had
gone up more than what we'd expected
they would make good on the extra
traffic that they had Wow
true is a very very very friendly
environment yeah
how do you expanded the team from seven
at that point it was only ever seven
because it's a it's essentially a server
game isn't it or you need this the space
family that's all right and around this
time you come to sell the company is
that right well we it was rumored that
we tried to sell the company in March
2007 after we just had it a few months
at the time I think we had 20 million
visitors or
about fifty half a million a day so very
kind of Roman see Steve harsh at Vivid a
little bit cool yeah
could they were massive yeah they still
are very big yeah when they were very
probably the biggest well they will talk
about Jameson at something a walk yeah
that's big huge and so we went to see
him we wanted a lot of money for it
because we knew where it was gonna go
because the traffic stats just just
don't lie he hounded us out of the the
office I wasn't there thank God but
security had to take us out told us that
we were not one saying that it's it's a
fad it's gonna die out and we were like
generalize is not gonna die out and it
didn't the price that you asked for that
day and the price that it eventually
sold for was a few years after that um
it was we actually sold 5th of May 2011
right so SEC four years later about you
the prices dramatically more was it I
can't really talk about it but it was it
be rumored what we were asking my figure
is by any chance
yes we we were asking a lot of money
back in March at the beginning of March
in 2007 and yet was a lot more that we
saw it at 4 in 2011 and so in that time
though had you worked your way into
where you wanted to work your ending you
you got into porn partly because you
also wanted to see yeah we'd we'd never
been on one set in
so you saw a car show developed between
we already knew that we were going to be
selling because we wanted it leads back
to we hadn't been on a porn set we've
been invited on some it's it's like we
were we still didn't trust the the
industry so we were hit up by a new can
company or another camp company they
said we'll send the private jet to you
come pick you up in LA come to fly up to
our offices and so me and my partner we
were like can't wait you should do that
what are you take gonna have would you
don't tell him anything yeah huge you'd
say like they can have a bed on there
they're gonna put can girls in there
we're gonna have a whale of a time so
the central one in our team was saying
yeah they're gonna like row here you're
gonna they're gonna have so much content
on you that you're gonna need to sign
over this new deal we're like and what
it's a problem so we we still didn't
really trust anybody see ya it was just
it was a real surreal we're a weird
weird tell so didn't you didn't go no
right we drove up there right you drove
here but you did we did go we started
meeting people face to face what was
going it was weird because they had no
idea what we look like as a mean ma'am
and sorry yeah it's meat in them and
plus I was always the guy that would be
they would go and meet people as well
like the the eyes and the ears of the
company I was yes I would go to the to
the shows I think first show I went to
was in Vegas used to go with a different
name on the tag different company and
that's where I got the moniker of the
youporn guy because everybody used to go
right and I just be walking through a
bunch of stuff with all the new girls
did you enjoy um no because you'd
everybody would want to come up and talk
to you sir
I used to have a business card I should
have brought one with me but it was just
black laminated card with youporn logo
and JT that's all it was right so you
pour logo so people used to come up and
pitch me to out blah blah can we do this
can we do that and say do you know what
yeah I'm moving your car and if I'm
interested I'll contact you and they go
okay do you have a card I go yeah give
him the card and they go there's there's
no contact details and go no and say
you're not going to contact me are you
look like no no sorry
it's not a service so there how can we
contact you you go do what you can't
Wow because we just we were happy with
with what we had because there's a
loyalty yeah that we had to our cam
coming as a dating companies their ad
networks because they started pre paying
for everything that we we stuck with
them from the very beginning right to
the very end that must also create
somewhat of an air of excitement around
you guys because it's so like don't call
us we'll call you
you know yeah it's good but it gets very
very boring having to say no at the
beginning I was like yeah okay yeah I'd
take a look at it and they used to work
out that my email address would be JT at
Newport or they'd give it a go to have
found you but it was yeah it was very
difficult beginning to say no because
people is so excited because you have
millions and millions of users a day
that they they knew that if they could
get access to that they would be making
an absolute fortune hmm you know so we
had to restrict because we were very
protective over our users our ad
networks we wouldn't let them sell
adverts to companies that would do video
ads because we didn't think it was right
that if you're watching appalling
oh that next to the the video player
would be to video ads scrolling of a
guy's dick going from like that to that
because you'll look anything like Blair
doesn't actually work also that's very
distracting so yeah very distracting
because for us we don't care if they've
they we want them to click on the
banners because we get paid more yeah
how did your igor deal with the fact
that all of a sudden everyone wants to
be your new best friend and you have the
powers yeah it was it was good but again
you knew that everybody wanted to be
your friend because of you poor not
because you're a particularly a nice guy
that you were vindicated that must've
been quite satisfying to walk around
because they're emerson be like we they
started to asked us to go on panel so
i'd start speaking on panels start
giving them insight into how we do
things why we do things and why we're
actually the industry's friend instead
of the enemy and when you often
challenged angry people no not that time
not the time so yeah i wouldn't wouldn't
want to put myself in that in that
position
yeah i'm you'd get one or two in the
crowd that were like still aunty tubes
right but those guys just aren't around
decide the people that didn't adapt to
the tube sites don't they they did die
out and we we kind of take we're kind of
pleased at it actually also cleansed the
industry because of the the stigma of
being in the adult industry is derived
from people but shouldn't really have
been in it it's the industry
yeah i've really liked with the adult
with with the tube sites it it meant
that they didn't adapt because they did
they just struck it lucky at a time they
film in their wives or their girlfriends
or anybody not getting the documentation
put on a website selling memberships and
they don't care about anything and they
all died out so you've you're tend to
left with the professional companies
that shoot really good like high-quality
sensual erotic content or the amateur
content quite pure i guess
like crack yeah and it's just the the
industry is shrunk a lot but the
industry is very close everybody is
there for everybody the the forums some
of the forms are amazed in some of them
yeah there are some private forums but
mainly for the adult industry so you
have to be part of the adult industry to
get into the forums and what sort of
things aren't is it like advice on how
to yeah anybody needs anything anybody
doing any good offers on dating or cams
or anybody use this CMS system what do
you recommend or what do you recommend I
do here or I've got a problem or like oh
my god have you seen the price of
Bitcoin and were you were you looking at
other porn sites at that time and sort
of look at their UX and sort of being
like oh those guys have got this we
should try that on our website or um
with youporn we we kind of knew what we
wanted to do so we never wanted to make
changes to the site we we changed the
logo because we had to because Google
were suing us because our original logo
was like seems to be like the the
YouTube we don't think that it was so
they contacted us with the cease and
deceased to hand the domain over to them
we at that point we thought our world
had completely ended because how can we
fight against Google you can't even get
a lawyer in America against Google
because they have every single like tier
one law on retention but we found a law
firm that were non retention so we
fought back and it was about six weeks
from getting the original letter to them
emailing to say there they're not going
to pursue so we changed the logo and we
we had companies the big marketing
companies to say to us right you need to
spend a hundred thousand dollars because
we'll help you change the the logo from
what it is to so this we actually spent
$16 a hand buying the license to a font
reached out to the kid that owned the
to say hey can we do you mind if we put
a star in the O instead of the love
heart that you have in the O is the
kinky font and he went yeah no problem
we paid him $16 we launched we liked
personal pains no caste or gray so we
launched the new logo and these
companies you can't do it's gonna be a
massive photo and go do you know what I
don't think anybody's ever gone on to a
website and went over the logo a logo
really it's a very small percentage I'm
thinking I remember some interviews I've
watched from a couple of years ago where
porn stars of girls have been talking
about the difference of the money they
used to make and the money they do
making and I'm aware that you're sitting
here but they might be a porn star
what should the city of your own I said
I wish I was there to criticize them on
this or that is the reason is there a
thing that you feel like you've been
criticized for in the past to do having
to do with you point unfairly is there
anything that you've been accused of
well there people are shooting less
content right then when we come along
because a lot of the company's not in
business anymore right so yeah there's
they're shooting a lot less content so
do girls and boys the performers are not
getting as much work the content that's
being shot is being shot by more
professional companies so you need the
performers need to work harder in the
scene they just can't turn up and the
guy points the camera then it goes
through so they they have to show
passions and this is where Nikki with
Nikki's models right that's the good
yes my girlfriend so she when we first
started with we were using lots of
different agencies and they were
terrible they just didn't give a crap
they would send the girls without
passports without ID we have all of our
full crew there waiting for the girls to
turn our pot they just wouldn't turn up
so we realized that we needed to create
we needed to be in control of our main
part of the business which was the
performance so this is no your it at the
content production yes usually you're
out of youporn you've sold you porn at
what point did you say you wanted to get
into me and pour yourself because
obviously yes and that was so I said we
in 2009 we realized that for us to see
naked girls
we need to own our own production
company this is just one long thing to
try and get you to see naked girls we
realized we're not well we were getting
invited to sets but we didn't really
trust any of the people that we've been
invited to to go look at the sets and
we're thinking like this is going to end
badly so we need to own our own
production company so we but we didn't
want to go through and set a production
coming out from scratch because it was
just too much hassle we've been in a
very similar position and the last year
so make a different content
unfortunately yeah so we we reached out
to a production company down in Portugal
because their videos were on our tube
site but they weren't part of our
content partner program which we
couldn't really work out because their
content was spectacular
I'm not going to name the company right
what made what makes their content
spectacular the the the way it was
filmed the girls they were all like
Czech Hungarian really really hot girls
but the girls had a
proper chemistry and the way that it was
really owed the light in the story lines
not that they really batter that's ditch
but it was just this content stood out
I've not the they had 38 of the top 50
most viewed videos on our website so
really yes we had so this guy reached
out that I know I need to hire you in
London
so I said actually I am I'm there today
he said I need I need to meet you
because I'm director of a company and
we're going through a real terrible time
because of you and I'm like okay but I
knew it was a safe meeting to have with
this guy so I'm when and had lunch with
the guy and he pulled these DVDs out and
put them on the on the site is this in a
fancy restaurant so no used to be a
member of the like a gentleman club
somewhere yeah so you go there yeah on
Shaftesbury Avenue right the media place
right yeah 100 no sentiment a century
right yeah so we were there and he
pulled out all of these DVDs and I look
to him I went I know this company yeah
and he went yeah
so I said these are really really good
so I have my laptop pulled up you buy I
said look they've got like 38 of the the
top 50 and I said why don't they join
our content partner program he said
because the guy that owns it absolutely
despises you so I went like holy crap
and he's gone our memberships have gone
from like 4,000 members which for them
were quite a lot but they they weren't
very good at the the internet thing they
used to sell a ton of DVDs but they just
weren't very good at the the internet so
they went from 4,000 members you said we
have just over 400 members and I'm like
oh my god I knew how how many members I
could send him in the first month let
alone if we did this over a long period
of time
I went just came to join our content
partner Perot he said he won't won't do
it so I said where are they based I open
that they were in England he said
they're down in Portugal so I went so I
said can we go see him
and he went he won't like seeing it so I
said but let's go down there I said
because if it get face to face with the
guy after he's over his initial hate and
if he wants to punch me he can then I'll
say to him how much money I can make it
so we flew down to Portugal the
following morning went down there must
separate do that but it was just I just
saw a massive opportunity because at
this time we were looking at acquiring a
production company and this production
company was on its knees
but it had the best content that I users
absolutely adored stars align normally
yeah yeah so we went down there so the
guy we went walking in the office he had
like a big house where all the editors
were neared a lot of staff down there so
we we walked in I was with this guy met
the guy they owned the company and they
said no Hussein said highs just my mate
just want to come down and show him that
the company so we had a nice morning
talking to everybody
I couldn't let on who I was they weren't
for lunch it was great then after lunch
we went back to the office sat around
the table and the guy said to the owner
he said I have been completely honest
with you this is JT from you point and
this guy went ballistic you ain't get
out what are you doing here
you've ruined my company and I'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah I said listen you've
got 38 of the top 50 videos blah blah
blah and he's gone yes I know and I'm
not getting a penny I went well why
don't you join our content partner
program the issue is your own fault
in theory and if you don't want that
content on there why haven't you sent me
a DMCA notice because then we could find
out who owned the the content and come
and do a deal with you see he was like
blah blah blah so I ended up speaking to
him for about an hour and just can't
move him down and I said okay now I said
I know you've got about 400 members I
said look let
do a deal with you I said we I said I
need 30 videos from you if you edit the
videos I said let me talk to your
editors you edit the videos it's out now
how I tell you to give me 30 videos
we're going to put one on a day at the
end of that month if we haven't got you
an extra 2,000 members paying members
then I'll give you no I said if we
haven't given you the two thousand
members in in the month I said I'll give
you whatever money that you want and
he's gone give me a thousand thousand
euros per video and I'll give you thirty
sorry okay I said so I'll give you 30
grand I said but we're putting in escrow
I was thinking I don't really have
something about the guy just didn't
really trust so in in the end we didn't
need to go down the escrow route the
editors they are edited 30 videos in I
we had a little like bet in the office
to say or dive with the other guys I
said we will get over 4000 video for
four thousand new members will sign up
to his thing it took seven days for from
the first seven videos going on we got
four thousand two hundred but we also
had a mechanic that if as soon as we
reached so many so many new members it
meant that he had to sell 51% of the
company to us for something absurd like
four five million euros but we were
paying we were gonna pay him that money
from his own money through the signups
that we would get him because we would
know that we could get to twenty thirty
forty thousand members within like a
four or five month period so we didn't
mind paying him all this money and we
were in it for long term plus that was
just the content partner program we knew
that we could give 10% of the adverts
and we could get up to 150 200 thousand
members with this guy's company he was
sit back carry on doing what he's doing
the team would carry on
what they're doing it's just that he
would have then millions in the bank and
he's gone from having a lot of money to
having next to nothing so we carried on
doing this tree here we ended up with
like 20,000 members that he had he would
never sign this contract and way of
thinking my like my partner said he's
he's never gonna sign this contract you
know that and we were getting our
revenue share through the affiliate
program so in the end we got on the
phone to this guy and we knew that we
could have out one of our tech guys
ready to just pull the plug on his
channel on new porn and all his videos
would disappear it's we got on a
conference call said hey you can sign
this contract just tell us yes or no we
think no so if it's going to be no just
be honest with us and we can just move
on and try and even know so I like
message the tech guy said okay pour the
videos now so you poured all the videos
I said like go on to go on to you porn
search for your videos anyway oh my god
you're insane you can't do this he's
gone you shouldn't be in control of this
website you're gonna ruin the website
blah blah blah
you're gonna lose millions of viewers
because his videos would have tens of
millions of views you can't do this blah
blah blah blah to roll on
so we did do it that we never let him
back on roll on two years I think he
sold his company for like three hundred
thousand and do you think it was he
wouldn't sell on a point of what he
considered a principle I don't you think
it was greedy right he wanted me just
yeah just wanted yeah we really made
quite a lot of you quite a lot out yeah
he made in that year he made is to make
about two and half a million dollars
which for him when you have nothing yeah
but what that actually did for us so we
that was August 2009 or end of August
2010 we pulled the plug his two main
camera guys they understood the power of
youporn
we then got a telephone call third of
December 2015 to say we want to buy
new porn by a company that we knew that
they could afford us so we went okay we
at that point knew that we were going to
sell you porn
a week after we agreed that we were
going to like I think mid-december the
two content guys from the company down
in Portugal reached out to say hey we've
had enough this company can you start a
company and we'll come and start
shooting content for you because
obviously that's what you want so we've
gone from selling you've all known that
we were going to sell you pawn on the
3rd of December to like the 15th of
December these two guys we started the
company 1st of January 2011 started
shooting content so we could launch the
sites and then we sold you porn in 5th
of May but when you saw the upon did you
not think about writing off into the
sunset
oh I mean I don't know what kind of
money you got but I would assume it'd be
enough
I wasn't like a major major partner in
new porn but certainly enough but what I
did actually come away with was nobody
wanted to do the production company so I
took the production company taxes for
yeah this is this is where I think
faketaxi was our eighth site right so we
we launched our first sites in September
to her like Dan Jones Lesbia we had cast
indirect settings and orgasms xxx
because we launched the first website so
everyone xxx
yeah remember when order to protect
people yeah
so what if a taxi cordon to sort of
mainstream culture the weight loss cause
everybody's been in the back of a taxi
so the reason that we thought that it
would be a success was because we we
knew from from youporn looking at the
satsang videos where you can actually
put yourself in a situation in the video
where is a normal situation not like
being in a bad weather with a girl but
something like getting in the back of a
taxi everybody gets in the back of a
taxi or you see manger
yeah with with Australia you're talking
et cetera and we just knew that for us
it was cheap content to shoot because
you just have the GoPros yes we just
have the Advocate we has a handheld as
well but we just knew that we had the
right guy that was one of the main
things that we needed to get the main
performer had to be right because he had
to be kinky almost like dirty needed to
have the the gift of the gab needed to
have like a charisma about him and a
really good performer and he's he's
pretty old now bless him but he's still
going strong you know yeah so he he we
we always know the sites that we're
gonna do but we have to wait for the
right person to be in to be the main
characters fake driving school we as
soon as we shop with with Ryan Ryder
because he was a professional actor he
was in Joseph and the Technicolor
Dreamcoat
in Scotland on TV yeah um riders in
order
loan yeah Leslie Ranger yeah so is the
predominant your your fake it just goes
fakeness yeah
so we doesn't it yeah but there is honey
how it come about because we were don't
fake news just are we only fight news
xxx I do remember a lot of people used
to talk about there being like stripper
news and stuff that was quite a fad for
the weather goes here this Dylan's rise
they still do they still do that Japan
they've got the news just the cub just
gliding noticing and on the next story
and the way the whole point is that they
have to keep a straight face the entire
time these Japanese fellas shut up with
them they're in some weird [__]
so yeah yes so yeah so you had you've
got you got that yeah and that's
somewhat proliferating the mainstream
because people have started using it as
a meme as well yeah the memes are gone
mental
yeah I actually so we we it's a reso do
porn we started a production company so
then we we grew very very quickly as a
production company because we were
really lucky the first four or five
sites that we launched with real huge
success but say that we're lucky you
could hardly get it wrong with the data
that I come out view porn with because I
knew what what people wanted to watch I
knew what they were clicking through
through the content part of her I know
what they were buying right and I knew
how to deliver those videos what the
videos needed to be on the tube site sir
our business model was we create
everything from the moment we picked the
camera everything has to be shot with
the tube model in mind you reduce
reserve
so because I didn't want to spend money
on advertising because I'd never spent
money on on advertise with you upon so I
didn't want to do it with with my
production company so we we knew the
only way that we could get members sell
memberships was through the tube sites
and the tube sites are free so you give
them your your videos so it was I'd say
that we're lucky that the first four or
five were a major hit but it was we
would have to be stupid to get it to get
it wrong this is actually because you
guys also knew the routine so you would
have gone on that affiliate of youporn
you would have done all that
so no new porn like pornhub xhampster X
videos well show you all of them show
videos yeah your faith what a mood
people perceive a threat you're the guy
that owns that lives in Prague yeah the
mosque enough because it's legal to do
what we do there right illegal to shoot
you can even shoot how in the open
that's why we do like public agent yeah
so you can have sexy when you soak the
production company who is the person who
gets to choose the girls or you saw yeah
no because you don't ever want me to be
in control of anything now because we
got divorced okay so somebody else to
Lois the guy that was in the the
portuguese raha production company he's
he he is the head of production so
everything that we've released
he's responsible for so is he casting
girls there okay um not casting because
you you just get the girls through he'll
fight he'll see a girl that he's seen in
somebody else's video right go on to
onto twitter instagram try and find them
have a look see what kind of character
she is see how she's done in other
scenes have a look to see if how many
videos she's been in then he will let
Nikki at Nikki's models know and then
Nikki would just get in contact with
that girl to say after company everybody
knows our company in the traders rusul
rusul are looking to shoot you most of
the performers they know about our
company because we shoot so many scenes
that if we like a girl we can give a
like ten scenes we'll fly them to Prague
from wherever they are and they know
that they could be going home
with six seven thousand euros in ten
days and I guess also they'll be well
looked after as well in that time
location we pride ourselves as being a
really really nice really fun production
company nazia the guys you get a lot
companies where the cameraman they'll
they'll touch the girls I feel that
they're an object that they're allowed
to do we don't sell any of that yeah you
still get companies to do that and the
owners of some companies that they'll
they'll feel that they are allowed to do
whatever they want with the right the
girls but they get very bad now that
this is a classic story of you know well
the custom culture that you have - we do
because we have fake agent and we have
female fake agent not some people
actually practicing that as oh yeah a
lot of guys that they'll start a website
which is our point of view right so they
have the camera that's precise shoot
though isn't it yeah but they don't
really care right too much because they
just want to get to have sex with a
beautiful girl that they're they're
paying for 500 600 euros to film a
professional scene and the guy is
actually just doing it for his own
personal enjoyment but he's created a
website tryin if he sells a membership
sales and memberships but we ought take
wait Nicky is with the model agency very
protective over her girls so if she sees
the a guy that has just got like a small
POV website she won't let him join
Nicky's models to book any other any of
the models because she she used to be a
model so she knows what goes on so she
can be very protective and has there
been any sort of kickback
everything in the mainstream media
recently has been about guys you know in
repeatedly touching girls and things
other things has there been a similar
thing in the porn industry um slightly
different industry but you've got to
understand the way that we run our
company and we've really install into
into our crews is that these girls are
professional models yeah they're coming
on to our location to do an actual job
so they sit down they give it if there's
a script they give them a script they
talk they they're told about what is
going to happen they set sat down with
the hair and makeup they're given their
outfit so they need to wear and we we
treat them not like an object of what
people could think that are they coming
on and obviously they're selling
themselves for for money they're
prostitutes and you can do whatever you
want I can have a feel they're up there
it's it's completely different on most
production companies it's it's very very
very professional right very
professional and then the as soon as
that scene starts that's that's when the
the sex happens but it certainly doesn't
happen on our location with the with any
other the crew and the performance and
after you got divorced you said you're
with Nicky now who obviously got a
cocktail this year on the shore and it
used to be a model yeah she would she
was a performer what was what is it like
for you was a book just a general blog
being with someone who's been a mother
before was either like an ego thing of
like hey I've got a porn star I
it's like test driving a car before you
actually make the commitment to buy it
so you can look online think yeah she's
pretty good at that
Oh yes--it's I don't really think about
it that much because I know he had to
because I mean you've got own sound I
have seen so much porn that I don't see
it as porn I see as like good points bad
points as like as numbers in pretty
almost a critical and art form in it so
I can rough I can look at I can look at
my anal video and I'm looking at the
different different angles yeah the
light in and like what did the girl do
or the air that girls are really good
maybe tell Lou that this girl's good or
is that a bit boring though because you
saw it desensitizes D desensitized so
nobody actually have sex is there any
part of your brain that is almost like
I've been sitting watching this for god
knows how many phones because I don't
look it look at it as porn anymore I
just it's just really really weird I
just look at it it's it's just just my
job you know to look it to you you're
not you don't realize that you're
looking at porn yeah because you're
looking at different things when you
look into your own content that's the
that's the the worst thing though I
never really give Lou any tips or if
there's something that I do see in the
video I like challenge him on it so hey
why why do we do this and he'll say are
we have to try and something out blah
blah blah but I'm I'm no expert in the
creation of porn but I've seen so much
born that I don't look at it as porn so
when when I'm with Nikki it's not like
sometimes I see like a position you
think I holy [__] yeah this do you think
as an industry not appreciative of it
deep do you think it's quite a creative
industry because a lot of people in the
outside just sort of think it's a very
formulaic kind of guys blammo comes to
our house yeah you were saying earlier
about the beginning
there was a lot of just amateur content
people just upload in their videos so
that still goes on but they're now
professionally produced you know it's
that's how professionals some of these
companies are they are creating content
that you don't even realize is not
user-generated and I guess it's a bit
but YouTube in a sense that they're sort
of pushing the envelope where TV can't
or where mainstream pause yeah but you
you have to you you have to be careful
like pushing boundaries in an adult
because billing because the fees are a
mastercard if you if you sell too close
to the wind fees or mastercard can say
hey we're not prepared to to bill for
your website and you are done and dusted
you don't you lose your your license why
because they don't want to yea PayPal
you I think PayPal you can get through a
bill a called epic round billing which
is good it legitimizes your payment page
having that PayPal logo on there can you
pound Bitcoin you can with some sites we
I started accepting Bitcoin cracking
about four years ago but just having
that Bitcoin logo on my pay page my
joins went down like 30 percent because
it looks a bit more CCD sableye oh my
god if they're into Bitcoin that they
there's something a child prostitution
and yeah guns drugs yes we take off
after after a week have you I'm heavily
into crypto right heavily sort of Lewis
talk so it's something I don't really
know a lot about we've had one guess
maybe two guests on the show but I'd say
Shawn that words that new kind of person
that would know about Bitcoin and Steve
I was all about like five years ago by a
side the side he was taught about 20 and
he was telling me like you've got to buy
you've got to do this right now
we had we had money and when Bitcoin was
at like $400 I downloaded the coinbase
app and tried to I bought like three
hundred pounds worth which the tower 250
pounds well whatever yeah which was yet
I was looking at this and that was my
weekly limit I was allowed on coin based
so they said apply for higher limits so
I applied send them my bank statement
which had a lot of money going through
the as you can imagine on on the bank
statement for a high net worth and they
declined and I just thought well balls
to you yeah so I'd I didn't get into
Bitcoin because of that I should have
pestered and should have gone on to
others biasing like oh it's not meant to
be didn't really think much of it but I
start to getting into Bitcoin heavily
about three months ago I wanted to start
getting into Bitcoin but I don't know
anything about the chart so I did an
online course for a month and to learn
about the chart the charts of flags and
that was yeah very very very worthwhile
so I start to trade in Bitcoin and other
like alternative coins about eleven days
ago and it's just seriously taken over
my life and I was even consider
considering I I had everybody was saying
invest the money that you're prepared to
lose so there I put my 10 grand into
into Bitcoin well it was that's why I
was prepared to lose but it was I wanted
to put an awful lot lot more in I was
even going to sell my Ferrari to put it
in Wow so that I could do with big retz
because I was doing tests like buys and
sells before I would commit to doing
anything so yeah I've been in it like 10
days full-on like 18 hours a day
so I'm twitching to go look at my
portfolio right now you're actually
quite late to the party though aren't
you in that sense in the scheme of
things y'all very very very very very
early right so if you are
to get into Bitcoin you would it says
now you can still get it in yogurt e is
never too late all of my kids are now
want Bitcoin for Christmas and made to
[__] prices my two son right no they've
asked for a bit really yeah because I
cited 10 days ago Joe and Harry Joe's 23
Harry just turned 20 a couple of days
ago so I gave them their Christmas money
and I lent them some money to fund their
their bit tracks account so they come
over to Prague last weekend so they
started in earnest on Monday and Harry
is his portfolios already 40 percent up
and I think Jose is like 28% Wow so it's
almost like a trust fund in a way yeah
it's like weird I'm trying to teach them
that you need stop losses because it can
go to zero bitcoin is like eighteen and
a half thousand dollars this morning
went up from 16 and a half overnight but
here it can easily go to a hundred
thousand it can easily go to zero right
and so what point D because the
mainstream media all the articles are
basically that bubble is gonna persist
we're saying it's a bubble bubble which
any economy yeah they want it to burst
yeah yeah the market can correct to add
a correction last Wednesday I think like
30% yeah right but now it's it's
recovered and it's I think 10-15 percent
up on what it was and the most reactive
to what what is the two news wanted to
rumors a lot of stuff coming out of
Korea because the the Koreans are
absolute some of the biggest investors
in cryptocurrency some people make
hundreds of millions out cryptocurrency
he had your higher friends of my tens of
millions one friend has made one hundred
and twenty hundred and thirty million
Wow and these are adults guys are in the
adult industry alright and that's well
and now that other there are other
currencies you say so what's this oh
yeah there's lots of different coins
I'm a cross training of coins
yeah well everything everything is based
on the Bitcoin value so you have like
this Satoshi so he goes down to like one
millionth of a Bitcoin right so you buy
everything in the amount of satoshis and
everything's relevant to the exact price
of Bitcoin at the time so Bitcoin sort
of like the US dollar in a way yeah and
have you ever experiments with Silk Road
have you ever been on their team they
Lulu not as a techie you couldn't quite
tech yourself I'm pretty non-technical
but to recreate data right and ya got
like have a normally good like gut
feeling for things okay so clearly yeah
I mean that's how I heard about with
Silk Road because I was about five or
five six years ago you may it was want
to buy DMT on there right and then he
was all about Bitcoin and he was tunnels
all of it he was like a scientist you
know the what he thinks this flat yeah
there's some rich really really rich
technical geeks out there yeah really
but do you there's there is a hell of a
lot of real wealthy under 15 year-olds
oh yeah you don't like the telegram some
of the telegram groups and you know that
these are kids like 13 14 15 your kids
are spelling yeah they're just trading
in coins and some of these they have
they must have tens of thousands all
those kids fifa coins and there could
have been living real some of these kids
are their parents would not know what
they are what they're doing and yet just
how much money that they actually have
but I'm sure these kids don't see it as
money they just see as i bitcoin and
they they're trying to grow their
Bitcoin as big as possible to me
they have no value of money at that age
but it is available to have the balls to
trade at that sort of level because I
have not respect
we had a poker guy on who how do you
describe Charlie I mean Charlie's got
he's on the spectrum on the spectrum
doesn't quite have the same social quite
fearless person they're not respected
and he says that really helps me when
I'm putting all the chips in like
because I'm not worried or as emotional
as the average person I remember there
was someone really good paper about how
in the modern age ignorance is actually
quite a really handy commodity to have
being in it but to the right things and
I think in many ways that's the case of
a Bitcoin is you have to be isn't a bad
word in that sense you just have to not
be fearful of those things you don't
have to do your own research yeah there
there's so many groups like the telegram
groups and Facebook groups where you get
people that give you a tip this should
do well give you an explanation a lot of
people are going blind and that's where
you get like the charts yeah that's they
call them pump and dumps you've got big
professional companies out there they've
got hundreds thousands of members in
these groups they say I'll buy this coin
sell it and all of a sudden it will go
up 60 percent and then within a few
minutes it goes back right back down so
you need to be in on these groups if
you're going to do that but the pump and
dump the the exchanges where you need to
go do this thing there call it of them
we're not talking about porn yeah
they're they're they're China outlaw so
if they realize you're being part of the
pump and don't think it's just gonna
close your accounts which is good
because it's just there's no regulation
it's just like a real maze essentially
yeah it just really isn't your opponent
it you know I was a dear potentially on
this yeah it does the porn business just
take care of itself it's what I did did
we go back to like going through the
through the divorce I was going through
a real terrible time so this would have
been - yeah 2014 do no question what
triggered the divorce or I went on my
first porn shoot
and yeah I'm just a golem my first-ever
point you my chances
yeah yeah go down to well no it didn't
but I kind of knew I spent so much time
away from home with you porn I'd say 70
percent of the four and a half years
about you porno with not at home and you
just grew apart and yeah so that was the
straw nothing wrong and I think that's
why we're friends that's why it was it
was awful for me because I felt so
terrible of what happened but yeah it
was just not a good time but you you
don't you talk about stereotypes before
you come on you don't really fit the
porn guys so am I the way I honestly
thought the fake tactic I was going to
end up you wanted me to wear face blah
no no no I just thought you were gonna
be sort of similar book demeanor - what
the-- you know say do you know i mean
they sort of imagine you as like gold or
sullivan type do you know what I mean
sort of Ryan you know you're talking
about you know the mistake you made all
over the killer you have four isn't what
you would expect the porn king to to say
you know here we have we have feelings
yeah so there are a lot of palm King
City um this is not yeah we know they
could because it's it's such a small
industry so everybody knows everybody
you don't know if they do not those two
because they're they're old school
they're also embraced oh yeah yeah so
the online industry is it's very very
very close you got any good friends or
who might heard of like you said um I
guess you would have more of the
performers yeah so it's like European
performers not I may be American
we don't we don't shoot in America and
we don't use that many the American
super have more curvy girls I think
that's why I end up on those ya videos
more like ron jeremy obviously you know
often in their mind he absolutely
despises me why because he said some to
you or a friend i'd met twice and it's
just made like a beeline for me since
Rachel and I I just get up and just
leave when she comes over do such things
at you does he um yeah just joins
conversation why are your the he's quite
me before night
yeah nice guy though yeah all accounts I
don't to be his friend so why do they
like you
because we definitely did the industry
where he was shoot in a hundred scenes a
month company's going our business only
shooting 50 scenes mates yeah he's got
his rum LeBron Jeremy Rand that's no but
I find them weird because I remember he
was shooting scenes very old and like he
was seen as a trophy for girls to
collect almost like oh yeah but he was
almost like good so he he would be stood
at the bar or sat at the bar he would be
talking to whoever he's talking to girls
would come along unzip his trousers put
his [__] out and like either suck his
[__] or just kiss his [__] and put it
back and he would just carry on talking
and it was like they were pen like
homage to to the king of like
performance and these were obscene porn
actress
- good see you yeah yeah good to see ya
that's more the kind of play and you've
seen that happen quite an unusual thing
- what not what we have seen a lot of
stuff yes it was though some of the
weirdest or surprising things that
you've seen any time in the porn
industry
um I don't know a lot that I'd wanna
speakerphones funniest thing but he was
actually paid to do it in one of the
Suites in Vegas they were do temp in
bowling with midgets right like you know
yeah well so they would believe us field
it was on the on the Flyers like [__]
bowling right that was pretty funny
yeah and then you grab them from the
other well well they just threw it
through the belt and right two fingers
earlier why I found quite interesting
was you said you cause to shoot that
like [__] bowling night lots of other
different there but honestly it's you
wouldn't want to talk about why believe
me would oh yeah I only want to talk
about a topic is it's quite sexually and
this is this is nothing we only started
going to the shows in 2008 right in like
the 2000 when it was when you so sure to
me like a video awards yeah avian shows
and like the expert shows on the
European summits and that and so you
were it's very calm when I started going
there I still shocked the stories I hear
from like years previous where they'd
spend $100,000 on a party just legends
on part
just a massive orgy or yeah lots of
things going on where yeah Berlusconi
probably know what about in terms of
pawn shoots one is the most extreme
thing you've heard of on camera
happening you can't um a lots of things
happen with like I know lots of like
disgusting dirty or rows where girls
haven't cleaned ourselves we have one
particular clip in the faketaxi
all right where the girl she was quite
ill from the bottom end oh yeah
everywhere yeah Three Valleys yeah but
we were out to dinner me Nikki and a
couple of like performers the other
night and we're saying to go I like take
some wine so I know like I can't I've
got an a North scene tomorrow and the
last time that I drunk wine and sure I
know the following day she said I just
[__] everywhere yeah you're like okay
thanks yeah well housemother they have
to you know I'm getting called true
Geordie well it's like then put this is
definitely not like in podcasting cuz I
can't relate this the podcast and we can
you work drinking on a coffin for our
podcasters yeah piss a lot yeah same
thing anyone quite interesting you
talking about you you obviously don't do
a lot of interviews and that's why we
were kind of surprised first of all that
we get an interval because we've always
spoken about doing well I tell you what
Rosie I didn't realize that Nikki
reached out to you but we are friends
over in Spain right Rosie and been
useful yeah Ben's been following your
since she was on like 5000 followers and
big shout out to shout out the Rosie as
well yeah she's at edit I wasn't sure
yeah she is she's very good of point
than one of the poll sites as well yeah
she had said she she works for the guy
that owns porn tube for two blacked -
she and vixen there
yeah flat is probably the best porn site
you're ever gonna see it's racial niche
black where we spend yeah where we spend
two three thousand on a scene he spends
15 20 thousand my job so put it this way
like for example the one I seen was
better quality than most babies they
shops like Steven Spielberg those like
this it looked very blue planet to
another level no it looked high quality
admit like a fake well you're not gonna
get any better this way it looked higher
quality than the kickoff yeah
the girls are really good-looking on
this yeah she works for that company but
I actually went when we so do porn we
started the production company I was
like really bored plus I knew I was
going to be going through the divorce so
I needed to do something to get out the
house so I actually do people go dog
yeah
guys the registry xxx they were going
through a real bad problem of the
industry hated them didn't want to xxx
so the guy that owns the registry
reached out to me and say hey you turn
do porn from people wanted to Korea to
people loving you can you come and try
and do the same job with xxx I went to
Florida for six months and we did we
have to acquire a lot of success with
getting dough xxx because everybody
trusted me as a you porn guy because we
didn't do anything wrong to anybody and
we we turned everything around that
everybody trusted us and loved us in the
end so it was a bit of a harder job with
Joe xxx but we had some success and then
my friend that I'd known for ages only
young guy he owned porn tube and for
tube he wanted to build content parlor
program so he reached out to me to hey
can you come and help us with the
content pilot program so I went here
corsican on the condition that I moved
down to Spain because that's where his
offices were I'll come come down there
Monday to Friday go home at weekends so
it suited me perfectly so that's what we
did we built him his content partner
program which really did is his websites
good but at the same time he could see
what I was doing my production companies
and how well they were doing so we would
talk a long time so hey you should get
into production anyway he got into
production and he has one of the best
production companies out there well he
is done really good really good so have
you got any plans for where you want to
take this cover yeah well so I was going
through the divorce mm-hmm I also I come
up with this concept because you you
need to remember we started youporn
we're right round we sold you pond
started a production company to utilize
the whole of the the the free porn sites
that were out there the free tube sites
I'd worked out a way that I could
disrupt an industry or a segment of the
industry that we helped create and like
the tube sites
I'd I worked out a mechanism that could
[__] them right so we started
building this it was called it was there
was three or four different parts of the
of the project the first one was called
cloud dot XXX where people would upload
producers or upload their content to us
because we we used to spend a lot of
time watermark in all the different
videos rendering the different videos
into 20 different formats we have worked
on every phone on every browser etcetera
etcetera so I had to build this this
protocol and this technology for my own
company but I realized that if I could
get everybody's content of people that
trust me because I've learnt them
millions and millions and millions of
dollars I collectively through the
content partner program through youporn
had the complete trust so I knew that I
could create an alliance so that we
could then fight against the tube sites
who we were all feeding from who we we
sold you Pont a big company at the time
it's called man win since changed to
mind geek man win wanted to buy my
production company really useful but I
would never sell it to them because I
had a road map of all the the new sites
that we were sure I couldn't possibly
shoot and launch new sites quicker but I
knew that they would be a huge success
and we just launched faketaxi
we first come on their radar I'd really
sold one company to they come to we want
to buy your company and say well you're
not gonna give me the money that I walk
forward because I know how big this
company is gonna be so come back in a
year come back in two years I'm not in a
rush so they kept coming back coming
back coming back so I knew I was going
to go through a terrible time with this
divorce so I needed to do something with
with my company but I didn't want to
sell it because we still had a roadmap
of really good websites that we wanted
to do plus at this time I knew that I
could create different verticals off of
videos or like different companies so I
knew that I was going to create model
agency and I knew the model agency that
I would create would be the best model
agency and be the biggest because I can
get the best girls to sign for this new
model agency because I can give them so
many scenes because I'm shooting so many
scenes so I I went over to Barcelona I
said a company up in Barcelona to do
cloud and to create this alliance that
all of the production companies that all
trusted me would join this alliance
collectively we had a massive voice
against the tube sites that wouldn't
listen to us individually so we had no
case against them so strategically
I leaked a document via a friend that I
knew was going to give it mind geek that
showed them the the road map that I had
planned for cloud and how I was gonna
destabilize the free tube industry which
is worth hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars that so I leaked
that Tim in August they've reached out
in September 2014 and and said hey can
you come a meet us in Amsterdam at the
the show that's on in Amsterdam so I say
yeah come and meet what do you want to
meet about they said ah we just want to
talk to about the content part of the
program ok I kind of knew that they were
going to approach me to buy the company
again it's a set down
I made it very clear and it they they
did want to buy the company
maybe very clear I didn't want to sell
it but I would lease them the company
mm-hmm which means we carry on produced
in all of the content they just run the
websites because they have hundreds of
thousands of members so just slot in our
stuff in there which is they own all of
the tube sites they own you porn pornhub
tube a red tube true bidet yeah they own
browsers mofos Digital Playground
browsers yeah they are never there like
a billion-dollar company so they bought
you porn from us so very good friends
with all of them very good friends with
the people that run the tube sites
because we were the best channels on the
tube site so I knew with the divorce
coming up I needed to do something with
my company because I couldn't
concentrate I was the only one that
generated the revenue in the company and
my revenue was going down I started to
not give a [__] about it which was
criminal but I started not giving a [__]
about not giving a [__] you know it was
I started going down in a like in a
sorrow without without not even knowing
it you know
so we I met them in Amsterdam
so they said I'll come on this this I
said only shooo my website's content
management a domain management deal so
we we struck up a deal 5th of December
2014 we signed the deal it was there
they're big they have like over a
thousand employees it was their big
Christmas thing over in Montreal so we
were there so we were announced on stage
that they'd just taken over they just
signed the deal to take over they call
us fake taxi even though we had like 22
other websites so everyone refers to us
as fake taxi
so Brian doesn't yeah so we me and Luis
were up on stage and everybody was
really cheer and whistling because they
knew that they'd they'd got some of the
best brands in the adult to join the
mind geek family so for us it was
perfect yeah it's a we we now sit back
we create all of the content and we sit
back with the profit that I was earning
the previous like 12 months we get it's
called a minimum guarantee everything
it's perfect so in that time they've had
it three years the end of this month is
three years they've quadrupled the
amount of members that I had and I
thought I had a lot of members so there
they're doing amazingly and we have full
creative control over the over the
content so three years ago I went from
16-hour days running the the porn
company running reduce or to zero doing
absolutely nothing doing 30 minutes a
month issuing invoices for the
production invoice and paying the staff
and I thought to myself this is gonna be
amazing
because Nikki was pregnant a hard time
though this is just gonna be amazing
yeah yeah unbeknown to me it was a
terrible time mentally I did like it
just turned me as a person you know
following for you already nothing to
think about
you know and nothing to think about so I
I found I start becoming jealous never
been jealous am I always like a
confident person you know always like a
good husband and since I good boyfriend
consider myself really really good dad
and I just I had everything you know one
of the world's biggest production
companies certainly the biggest
production company in in Europe
we'd had you porn for chrissake
everybody knew who I was that I wanted
to know I'd walk down Canterbury and
Harry's friends Joe's friends or I'd get
like kids teenagers even like 20 year
old shout-out youporn I hated liked
around and just like just waved like we
have my Lamborghini had youporn like all
down the side and again the since all
about but the fragra getting that
wrapped in faketaxi so it's gonna be
like everywhere in Prague I go all the
restaurants we go to the bars everybody
knows like who who we are never but is
it right yes it's it's just it's it's
great loved it but I could sense
something in my brain wasn't wasn't
right and it's thinking and I was like
thinking is the divorce divorce was
people every always say divorce was
terrible divorce was bad because it's
it's an emotional rollercoaster but the
poor girl she hadn't done anything wrong
I've been with her for 15 years we've
been married a long time we have five
kids and she she didn't do anything
wrong ever didn't have a credit card
didn't spend just saved everything for
the kids didn't have any brand-name
stuff let me go and do youporn them to
everything and her reward was I'm
leaving you right you know it was just
yeah whatever so hard well it worked
really really hard but the moment that
I've made a success of my life and I was
like tell boy or saying yeah this time
next year we're gonna be millionaires
who you pawn come along and this time
next year it arrived you know and yeah
and
I left her but what you're saying that
was it wasn't a divorce that was sudden
you down it was the fact that you could
be yeah I thought it was was a divorce
but I didn't realize that that I was
spiraling into depression and to because
I sing in you can't be deprived think
about look in the mirrors and think oh
I'd sit there for like 20 minutes just
staring staring at nothing I'm thinking
of absolutely nothing and the thing
about bloody out I could put you live in
my car
anyway it would happen and just think
nothing I think can't happen to your
Katie or the new porn guy you've got
this big potassium you're doing so
successful you've got really lovely kids
you can't but that couldn't even let
Nicky go down the go down the shop it
was already weird well you weren't you
were yeah just because I become very
dependent on her you know and she was
working so hard with the agency and I
was thinking okay I've done this deal
now not only did they did they buy you
porn from us but that project they'll
turn you about clout they actually
bought that from me so that they could
rip it up and throw it away so that I
would not launch that and we did the
deal for them to take over my production
company so I still owe in the production
company you mean Lewis still owned the
production company but we just produce
content and I don't have anything to do
with the content so I do literally
nothing could you do a bit of a J I'll
be there on picture have you ever heard
of this where basically
Corrigan agrees that he's gonna unite
everyone against jail B and then all of
a sudden you get some but a check of
course I don't even maybe not okay
I'd only spoken to five people about
doing this to my promised a lot of
people that know the palace yes it
sounds a little bit forgive me it sounds
a little bit like you're the guy who
works all his life to get everything and
then it's just this obsessive like I
want to be this person
and then you've got they want Daniel
alright ya know what I [__] do oh
yeah I got there I'd need it I didn't
need to do this third deal width with my
gate because I would have loved to have
gone through and done clout and seen
clout through the four different
mechanics he had to go through to get to
the disruptive technology that I needed
to need it to be at and to create this
alliance it would have crippled the the
tube sites did you ever worry that
someone else would do that though no
because you it's only the run in a big
tube site I don't think anybody would
realize that you can do it but you also
need to own the ton of the best content
right to be able to to see how to be in
a powerful position yes I was in a
powerful position because 80% of my
videos that in the top top 2% of most
viewed eyes rated videos on the tube
sites right so I'm in a very very
powerful position everybody else knows
that the tube size know that the content
producers they they know that too so you
were good personally you mate with yeah
so they wanted to do that but in my mind
I needed to do something to make mine
geeky that come through and pay me a
shitload of money for the for the
company or that they would let me do the
the lease in them right their company
okay so you're at this point now where
you're in that downward spiral yeah I
didn't this this down was born it was
like get a job just go do something I
swing to my palm partner and he was
saying just go volunteer just just go to
like a startup factory go find somewhere
in Prague where you can go and just help
people don't ask for anything you don't
need anything just just reach out boobs
anybody need any help with anything I'm
under a real severe non-compete contact
contract so I can't help anybody in
adult with their adult company so I
didn't have the confidence to go and
help someone in mainstream because I
only know at all
and why does if it doesn't work in major
I'm gonna look a right prat if if it
doesn't work out sir that knocked my
confidence though I didn't call me he'll
also get a sponsorship see ya 20% is
yours so we say yeah I didn't realize
but I just powered into like into like
rural depression and it's just weird it
can affect different people different
ways and I just thought I was really
really strong so yeah at the end it just
all come to a head last yeah a few
months ago in September really well I
just realized I needed to get help
you said is this one you said you
stopped drinking in smoke when I wasn't
drinking heavily leading up to the
meltdown there was a couple of weeks
before I left Nicki and yeah sir it was
just they'll know he's a time to go uh
oh no oh yeah yeah we I think we
finished about 20 times in about a month
that was like oh yeah but Nicki she
could see what was what was happening
with me and it's saying like you need to
go get help
and say like yeah of course you think
that I'm mental yeah you'd want me to go
get help and I could see that she
generally like loved me and wanted to be
with me wanted to Erin making the family
and and yeah so I went and got help and
good for you it sort of just counseling
and talking to people yeah it was really
weird because I obviously I live over in
Prague and have done for quite a few
years so I just Google counselors or
psychiatrist english-speaking found one
phoned him and went there I didn't
realize over different types of
counsellors yeah this particular one I
went to was just one that you voice
everything to they don't give you any
advice but I didn't know this so I
booked an hour with her thinking I'm
gonna need more than an hour so I sat
down with her actually I don't know she
said okay so tell me what that was wrong
so I started talking and like next thing
I realized she's looked at what she went
kaor hours up and I'm like [__] I've
just told you everything you so I've
opened this really big wound you're
gonna need to give me some advice
because I need to like yeah I need to
close there and she said would you like
to come next week so I went well she
definitely industry and so I said yeah
come come back nice right so I go now
and I drove them my fryer should've got
a taxi did you think of it I thought I
was gonna go there I'm gonna be all
better everything's really good
my sat in my car in the in the Ferrari
sat there wouldn't put the keys in the
car and just I was just staring at a
tree for like 30 minutes
Niki was i how are you getting on what's
happening what you doing bah bah bah bah
I'm looking at the message it's just I
just staring thinking I shouldn't really
drive home hmm you know because I'm I'm
not in my body you know isn't yeah I
drove I don't know how I got I got in
and I stood on the like the nests of the
the island in the kitchen just there
just looking out the window for about
two hours and Nicki was like with Lily I
look baby and she was just like I do do
what you want to do and no it's just
like stamp two hours and then just burst
into tears and she's like what is wrong
I said you know I just think I've just
done the the world's worst thing I've
just told this woman that I don't know
told her absolutely everything and I
just felt like so vulnerable so she got
online found another psychiatrist for me
to go see like did emergency appointment
so drove me down there like two hours a
two-cent with this guy for like three
and a half hours come out there like how
past 11:00 at night felt completely new
person he'd draw in things and
so he he saw mud oh yeah it seemed like
a couple of days later and then like a
week later and they could made like
tablets to stabilize like what is wrong
these are kind of things yeah they're
for the serotonins because that was
really low from where I was drinking
that was coming really low but it's over
a period of time but we went back to
when I was like ten years old things
that happened and one of the recent big
things oxic mum passing away or never
grieved for for mum never even cried at
the like the the cremation and do you
think why no don't know things but go
back to three it was about four years
ago it was the first time that I'd ever
bought a really nice girl bought Ferrari
like four or five eight specially brand
new so my uncle yeah it was amazing in
red yes right yeah it's a my uncle the
I'd considered to be like my dad my
whole life right put on Facebook bought
this car waiting for the delivers like
week delivery he hit me up crying on the
telephone Joe because he called me Joe
Joe they're gonna lose the farm lived it
like on a big farm people lived in
caravans around the farm gonna lose the
farm a mortgage company calling in I've
been making my mortgage so as I shared
and he said I need fifty thousand so
it's like thinking he's never gonna rip
me off and I went I can get the money
but I just spent all of my money on this
freaking car so I need you to go borrow
the money I said I can get the money
but it's whatever the interest is gonna
cost you need to pay this this money
back and how quickly can you pay me back
and he said I definitely got money
coming in two months to pay back so okay
so I went borrowed this money they
wanted $10,000 to lend me $50,000 and he
needed equivalent of 50
thousand dollars so I send it to him I
called him four days HSA said like you
definitely didn't pay this manner you
said oh I got some bad news
I've been let down on that - I'm not
going to be able to pay you back and I
just don't okay but that had one of the
biggest effects on me mentally it's rude
like that made me stop trust in
everybody
[Music]
closest person and be like in my life I
used to fly him over to Prague once a
month we would say he never used to pay
for anything used to give him money you
send him money to his account what did
you do after that we talked to him as I
am
do you cook people are you yeah for me
large for example Lawrence is very
forgiving and I'm quite cut through I'm
not not forgiving mmm sir I haven't
spoke to him we yeah it's not a grudge
sort of thing it's just you can't just
can't yet just can't believe that he
would do it to me and but that was the
catalyst for my depression yeah and for
losing trust in absolutely everybody oh
yeah a lot which is coming at you
because I kept trust with words Lewis my
business partner there is in control
words at all of the production because
hemacue you Nicky I lost trust with good
Nicky the father you weren't all the way
about when you're like whatever a nice
tie turning into being a right art oh
really you lose trust I think you just
say everybody's out you - how do you not
show a lot as well yeah they've become
very very quiet almost like an army you
don't want to go out because you don't
want to trust me but you thinking like
you go out don't mind spending two grand
on champagne but now you're thinking
these are souls are only here because
I'm spending two grand on camera and
where they've been your friend through
everything you know and it's not their
fault that they can't buy the champagne
and they're not asking you to buy the
champagne yeah but my mentality changed
yeah it's because the one person or
one of the few people who trust for so
long yeah cuz it'll serve my earliest
memories were see so much work that we
work that out but work that out yes in
September is has been pretty pretty good
so it was really understanding when you
think and yeah I'm green programming
that way yeah what also helped me was
Nicky said September to October she said
you need to go do something yeah
so I decided that wanted to get into
cryptocurrency so October I found the
online course that did the online course
so I could understand the the graphs did
some practice trades then started like
ten days ago so now I'm doing
cryptocurrency like 18 hours a day yeah
so all of sudden I've gone from doing
nothing like 30 minutes a month to 18
hours a day Nick is actually hating it
because I'm not sure now any attention
because crypto is my new girlfriend I
knew one of these guys thought you're
someone who needs sort of compose it
you're a pair don't assume remember
dates for easily yeah all of your date I
can't remember dates not with all of the
girls but I feel like I'm one of those
who I
I need a sort of world win lifestyle
where I'm constantly doing something
like all day like no no I just
okay hiya I was literally sat at the
table like that
Nicky would be there on a laptop I was
watching Nicky working and I do funny
little like Instagram videos oh hey
Nicky what you doing she she would just
look I'm gonna I'm making money honey
and she is just making a ton of money
with their agency sir its I was
disturbing her work and she was like
you've got to do something you got to do
so I so you just want to get rid of me
out the house and then that would start
the [__] you should get a tiny little
[__] but the text would come in like 20
past 10:00 at night thinking every
single night she would get a text
I didn't realize but every time I set
the alarm she would get a text
notification and say the alarms been set
on the house
I didn't know so I was thinking like a
Texan a good night yeah and then I would
be laying in bed thinking do you feel
quite fragile at the moment although not
northern mother I feel very very very
happy now September leading up to
September yes because for me the the
meltdown that I had in September my two
oldest kids were there Joe Megan so that
wasn't good for them to take what was it
in the room with yeah or the yeah they
was in the house so they know exactly
what what was going on was going I'm is
that quite an outburst in a way yeah
yeah quite graphic and so for them that
I suppose seeing your dad go through
that right so your dad go through it but
at the same time you you would you'd
need to know
yeah the graphic details I'm glad that
it was the older kids like well I wish
they weren't there but I'm glad it was
the older ones are not the younger ones
because they can they need to adjust and
they they need to adjust to the
situation to the the issues and the
problems that I have because these these
problems yeah I feel great now but these
problems that were identified in
September are gonna be there for the
rest of my life you don't all of a
sudden become better yeah if you if
you've got like mental disorder it's
gonna be there with you all the time
yeah my dad's got bipolar disorder and
it's something it was quite weird when
when he had his sort of I remember I
wasn't seeing him at the time when I was
when I was a kid but he posted a laugh
through me doll and he thought he was
stumbled on some sort of scientific
formula and that yeah you know he was
having a breakdown basically a time or
whatever you want to call it an episode
and and I'm a realist
I mean mom sort of explained it was all
right your dad's not very well at the
moment
and this is all going to be sorted out
in time but right now you know this is
what's happening and and now even now he
says things and I'm sort of aware of his
illness is always going to be there but
because he's getting the right help and
he's and he's well looked after yeah you
are less and less aware of in you're
able to just say it's just art it's just
art being dark Jim alluring but you know
you're not diagnose yeah I think no it's
just so the the good guys I went to see
after the woman that just drew things in
a book he just said like your serotonin
levels of ready ready down because we
had to do things from when the earliest
memory I had right up where I was the
highest psych with you porn and then
with a divorce down here blah blah blah
and I had to show him on the graph where
I was and I think it's just pretty
standard stuff that he was doing but he
was listening to apt earlier everything
and he drew this boat on the water where
you had like two little islands coming
out and you're in the boat and you can
go around them because they're little
issues those islands are problems but
when you serotonin levels are down you
then see the bigger picture you've got
the like the base of the the islands or
the the icebergs and everything that
used to be a tiny little problem is an
absolute mountain that you can't get
round and it just made out to complete
sense and it was just like someone just
a weight off shouldered say hey look
you're not you're not crazy you're not
gonna keep going like downhill because
at that point I was just thinking this
is just gonna get worse I'm going to end
up killing myself in like what the kids
gonna do then yeah it's just really
weird and sewed but it's really once I
spoke about it because Nicky had spoken
to my ex-wife because we were like I'm
good friends with my ex-wife because we
got the five kids together
Nicky reached out to her because she
just really didn't know what to do so
she was really really good with with
acacia
each other because because they both
care not because not particularly
because I'm a nice guy but why I have so
many children yeah yeah and and they
they kind of rely on on me purely purely
from a financial perspective on a on a
financial perspective they need me to be
saving as much money and to invest in as
much money making as much money because
there's only so many cars you can overs
we don't live in a particularly big
house because we don't need a really big
house but we love this approach back
because obviously some of people with
the amount of money that you might have
oh yeah yes massive house
yeah it's I've never used to have like a
lot of money but it's always lived in a
nice house and Nikki she bought this
house as an investment we were going to
then buy some land and build a house in
Prague
and take like a three years over it was
gonna pay for it yeah then we had an
armed robbery in our house trading
product or a trust but luckily we
weren't home so they and they come and
took our great big safe out of it was a
hidden safe in our bedroom we come home
there's just police everywhere yeah and
there's a hole in the in the wall
they've taken the safe or they're
conducting in the safe everything was in
the tiny little safe in the office
downstairs yeah yeah but the fact that
some have been in our house so Nicky had
already bought this house for an
investment and we're was like [__] let's
move into that house so that's that's
where we live now we have everybody
knows it is a satellite dish house
because it's on quite a main road and
for me to get sky and everything I have
to have like a three point two meter
satellite dish yeah I mean you don't get
sky
my country's just like the porn videos
to the spacecraft yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're open out there the American Way
opposed to the crooked one Oh No one
thing that I do find quite seems you
speak in before we got into this I know
one thing I did my machine an hour
already
yeah well two hours bloody one thing I
did find quite interesting was you were
talking about previous interviews you've
done and obviously you've not done a lot
understandably because I imagine you're
quite oppressed target in a way sort of
pin it on him he's the bad guy in this
one yeah about and you've been on canal
plus I think it was a French channel
yeah where they tried to pin something
on yeah another guy who sort of took the
moral high ground against porn yeah or
what he considers the moral high ground
yeah is that something you've ever if
you ever gotten into that rabbit hole of
the morality of porn and all that side
um yeah you tend to when people reach
out for an interview just okay give me
send me the questions you want to ask or
I'll send you a list of questions I'm
gonna allow you to ask me just so that
you're in complete control of everything
yeah so it was is only because what
rosie was saying about you guys that
just go there have fun just speak about
what you want to speak about they're not
gonna push you for a name and she just
said it's if you're gonna do this once
they do er these guys so yeah Rosie big
fan Rosa Casa de dólar yes she she made
my mind up the I wasn't in a particular
rush d'azyr didn't really care if I
never spoke about it yeah you know sir
yeah it's just time and everything
aligned and I'm here do you get do you
get challenged often by people who's
always and not friendlier it's auntie
yes no no no dude especially not in
Prague because it's theirs it's just
accepted over there you know it's just a
good thing and you don't seem to be one
of those bad guys in that sense thank
you very soon we have just such a good
good reputation yeah
from from the youporn days we have a
good reputation for being like a solid
company that everybody wants to shoot
for us because the girls know they're
going to be looked after and we give
them through become lunch if they're
there shooting late they all get dinner
they just really pampered but as a as a
production company every single Luis is
so good production because every single
piece of content that we put out
everybody the works for us in the in the
Edit inside and the production side
every single bit of work that they do
has to be the best representation of the
brand that they're shooting for and if
you can install that into every single
member of staff then everything you do
is going to be great and everybody
shares in in in the rewards too
you know sir it's where we pay more
money than anybody else for editing
further for the film crew because we
because we can you know some pride oh
yeah but Luis Luis has installed a into
all of the all of the stuff it has to be
the best representation of the brand
even if it's just a one minute trailer
we put out has to be the best I mean
yeah some of the writers may I
appreciate though I'm saying respect
people who who actually take pride in
their work I was just wondering in the
industry when Hugh Hefner died what was
it like for everyone because he's sort
of seen as one of the gods of form but
he will always be admired
right and totally respected because of
what they actually did he took us
completely mainstream you know sir
a forefather in a sense for you oh yeah
it's just it's one of the most
recognizable if not the most
recognizable brand in the world let
alone just in in adult yeah just just
really admired what what he did company
went through some terrible time either
its struggling but its Peter
number one by oh my god yeah yes playboy
was just you to see kids with playboy
pencils on school on their pencil case
it was just it was a brand that was in
effect a porn brown but wasn't a porn
brand and it was a mainstream brand and
wasn't and it was just the most
cleverest thing ever bunny with these
two little ears
it didn't really adapt did it no but I
think he'd made his money at that point
um he was getting to an age where he
really really Firebirds
lessons' you get all those yeah you'd
reached a pinnacle isn't there I've got
many more questions do you got much
choice
I'm just been really fascinated by the
story you told I'm really grateful you
come on a bit so we appreciate this it's
not often you get to meet someone II
mean just a little bit more open than
what I thought I was gonna be yeah
apparently I've got quite enough for
that would buy this yeah it just feels
like once you've opened the tap it's
yeah I think people appreciate because
actually the story you've told me
actually I think quite empowering story
that you know you've built something
based on not just you saw an opportunity
and decided to just go and what people
need to take out this is its you can
have so many failures it doesn't matter
just keep keep going because you're
you're destined to do something no
matter what what that is but you have to
believe in people you have to like trust
people and you have to like believe and
trust yourself and believe in what
you're trying to do but you if you need
to have people around you you need to
have the best people around you
but I don't micromanage anything so
everybody we've ever employed for the
role that they need to do they just get
on and do that role I don't want to be
making decisions for them because
they're not going to intentionally make
a bad decision to cost you money or to
be detrimental to the company how have
you found those people because that
that's something we participate through
the people that you already employ right
um because I think it's Google higher in
that way so the Google employees if a
job comes up but they say oh he would be
really good now they have responsible
for that person so the editors who are
really important in in our company they
were all recommendations from other
editors that we have so they bring them
under their wing they they say well you
need to do this very I mean not like a
recruitment company and it's it's very
hard to recruit people I remember we got
one of our editors I found him on
Twitter and he was a xxx editor thinking
like how he's editing like really really
good content for English English girls
so I reached out to him and say hey like
we're looking for a new editor would you
be interested blah blah blah
they went yeah okay sir I said speak
below it'll send over some content oh
yeah edit that send it back we'll see
what it's like and he did a really
really good job let's reset okay which
we often my full-time job but hey where
do you live and he went are in
Canterbury so I said 15 miles away and I
went oh bloody hell I thought he was
like America or like wherever you were
and ended up that he was he was friends
with one of my friends there's just a
really very small world yes sir it's
hard to recruit people for the porn
industry because they like all the [__]
don't touch born yeah I said well I pay
a little bit more money than mainstream
porn yeah
yeah funny good word you know guys Chris
editors he he had to stop working for us
in Juneau year round about June I think
it was he had to stop because his
girlfriend just couldn't take anymore
right
editing nakos any purpose for like oh he
needs yeah and he was like guys I've got
leave and I'm like oh he was like well
our first employee Wow and he said I'm
sorry I want to continue but I can't
it must be interesting because you spend
majority of your life in this industry
whereas actually other people dip in the
power of the industry yeah in 11 years
so I'm what 47 46 your longest career to
this point really yeah I was a dog
breeder before that was my tango when I
used to I used to have a mastiff yeah
massive star dog that was huge that was
very lazy sir every time they would
bring [__] to the house he was I oh
I'd look and think oh my god don't do
this to me I can't be bothered
so I'd have to lift him up and help him
out a little bit and he was well that's
how you want to be remembered by
I'm asking you final question that
Island ask everyone how would you like
the fear of effort um it's the you pawn
Kai is I'm a fooi
yeah yeah oh yeah as a business but like
be weaving on a personal level just as
the best dad ever
that's brilliant well it's been an
absolute pleasure minute thank you very
much I wouldn't normally link people's
their websites but I think you all know
what this guy's affiliated with now you
can search on Google if you've enjoyed
this interview make sure you hit the
like button stay subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you later